should you quit your job to start a
business this is a fantastic question I
got from one of my youtube viewers love
you guys dabka who wrote in the say hi
Evan thank you for your motivational
messages I'm Dhaka and contacting you
from Mongolia I work as a marketing
manager at a mining company even though
the salary has been doubled my previous
work I just hate my work and some people
I work with this company is filled with
old people and what they do to you is
constant pressure I'm seriously thinking
about changing my work not as a
marketing manager but as I don't know
what I think I do better is translation
from ongoing to English or vice versa
I would like to work as a translator
however the big question is will I get
paid as good as my current job I'm a
father of a cutest boy and have a twin
baby coming soon and bills to pay I just
can't make a decision
I thought maybe could give me some good
advice my wife encourages me a lot and
supports my every decision but I just
can't make wrong decision now hope
you'll get back to me with an advice
have a good day
Dhaka this is a fantastic question one I
think a lot of people go through and
it's a hard decision to make when you
are leaving big money on the table
especially when family is concerned now
I don't know much about you your
situation beyond what you wrote to me in
that message but what I do know is you
will not get very far in life if you're
doing things that you hate you not going
to accomplish anything great if you're
doing things that you hate hey that
right you're not going to be a happy
person if you're doing things that you
hate I understand the need to provide
you need to give your family your wife
your son your twins on the way a stable
income what I'd also encourage you to
think about those what kind of life are
you providing them if you're coming home
everyday angry and upset what kind of
husband are you going to be if you're
coming home frustrated and pissed off
what kind of father are you going to be
to your kids if you're coming home every
day angry and and freaking out compared
to what kind of family life you're going
to have you come home every day
energized and excited because you're
doing work that really drives you now
unlike many people I don't recommend
burning the boats and just going all in
I don't think you should quit your job
to start your own business it's going to
be way harder than you think it's going
to cost way more money than you think
it's going to take way more time than
you think to get this business off the
ground
instead I'd embrace the genius of the
end
and do both start your business on the
side while you are still at your current
job make your mistakes learn the ropes
start getting some customers modify your
product and service offering until you
have something that works while you're
still making an income because too many
people dive all in quit their jobs and
in three months have to go back and get
another job because they've run out of
money and I don't want that to happen to
you
so start part-time half an hour to an
hour every single day to focus on
growing your business and when you're
making enough money that you can afford
to quit your job then you can take that
step you don't have to be making as much
as you are that current job but you have
to make it enough to be able to put food
on the table and provide for your family
because as long as you're doing work
that you hate you're never going to be
able to do anything great or live a
happy life
now as a bonus tip I'd also try to find
work that relates to what you want to
get into if you love translation
services see if there's any opportunity
within the mining company right now to
do translation or look for a translation
job at another company that you could
jump to because at least you're getting
paid to do work that you love and learn
about the business you'll make mistakes
while getting paid to do something that
you like it's like going to translation
business school and getting paid to do
it
you'll make far fewer mistakes when you
launch your business and I'll increase
the chance of you being successful
believe for you guys watching I love to
hear your story of how you how you broke
out how did you quit that job you had to
start your own business what fears did
you have what motivated you to do it
share your story your advice to other
people who are faced in a situation
right now can learn from it and get
inspired leave a comment below with it
and if you liked this video and you want
to see more subscribe to the channel
thank you guys so much for watching I'll
see you soon I'm Calvin way I'm a
singer-songwriter
personality I subscribe to Eva's
newsletter a few years ago it has really
helped me the newsletter is very
informative and inspiring and it has
helped me throughout my career so I
encourage you to don't give up you can
make it subscribe to Eva's newsletter
today you won't regret it
you